[Music]
children all over the world love to play
with toys but sometimes toys can be a
bit creepy stay tuned to the end to see
a doll that attracted quite a lot of
controversy if this is your first time
visiting the things then give this video
a big thumbs up and hit the subscribe
button today we are going to show you 20
creepiest toys no kid would want as a
present face Bank money boxes are useful
and an old-fashioned piggy bank is a
great way to teach kids how to say
however this money box gave us the
shivers it's called a face Bank and its
name suggests it's a money box but it's
shaped like a face and you put coins in
its mouth it's battery-powered so you
can see it eat the money there is
something pretty unnerving about it it's
got an odd blank sort of expression and
you could imagine a kid actively not
wanting to save its pocket money rather
than having to deal with it
Little Miss no-name it's good to teach
children to have compassion for those
less fortunate than themselves but back
in the 1960s doll makers Hasbro came up
with a toy that ended up creeping us out
they decided to design a doll that was
homeless and her story was that she had
been abandoned they called her Little
Miss no-name you can see that she is
skinny dressed in rags and she is crying
if we had been given this toy as kids we
aren't sure whether we would have tried
to make things right for her by showing
her love we feel like we'd probably
scream and run away
hopping later hosen a little wind-up toy
is a traditional staple of any child's
toy basket so it's pretty cool to see
how one company used modern technology
to bring it to a new generation
unfortunately it's been done in a way
that's rather weird and pretty
disturbing the toy is a pair of later
hosing clad legs and you can use a
knockwurst shaped remote control to get
them hopping over you doesn't it look
like the weirdest thing ever but that
isn't the only creepy thing about it you
see these aren't just hopping later hose
and legs know this messed-up toy yodels
at you as well
swimming doll there's a belief that
things were better made way back in the
Victorian era in a lot of cases that
might be true
but sometimes things that might have
looked appropriate then no longer look
appropriate in the modern day this
fringe toy is a great example of such
case you were given a key and when you
turned it the doll looks like it was
swimming except it was doing it on dry
land not water when we look at the toy
now it just looks really odd it looks a
bit like it had all its limbs removed
and put back on the runway fearsome
flush if you were a kid growing up back
in the 1980s then the chances are you
know what a big deal the Real
Ghostbusters was the cartoon spinoff
from the classy spooky action comedy was
everywhere well there's going to be a
bit of spookiness with anything to do
with ghostbusters we think that this
takes things too far
it's a toy of fearsome flesh a villain
from the show basically it's an evil
haunted toilet and it's got eyes teeth
and a tongue - who you gonna call
definitely not a disturbing toilet toy
Hugo man of a thousand faces in the
modern world we realized that it's okay
if boys play with dolls however back in
the 1970s it was looked down upon but
did you know that sometime akers tried
to break the mold even back in the day
however in this case they just gave us
something disturbing
Hugo man of a thousand faces was a bald
male doll but with a big range of wigs
and accessories so he could look however
you wanted him to look unfortunately we
think that most of the looks he had were
less fun and more creepy however we
might be in the minority here that's
because this strange rare toy actually
sells for quite a lot on internet
auction sites baby laugh a lot the idea
of a demonic repossessed evil doll is
something that is a little bit of a
horror movie cliche that has maybe even
lost its impact however when we saw this
next toy we got scared all over again
it's called baby laugh alot and it's
genuinely spooky as its name suggests
it's a doll which laughs however there
is something really weird and creepy
about it it rocks back and forth all
while issuing a high-pitched laugh which
we'd say sounded more like a carful
it came out in the early 1970s so we
wondered if it may have inspired any
horror films no thanks we'd rather not
give this as a present
my thirst bacon unless you don't eat it
because of religious or dietary reasons
we think there's a good chance you like
bacon so what could be better than a toy
bit of bacon for your child well as it
turns out quite a few things this is a
plush toy which is supposedly streets
with bacon however it doesn't quite look
like the color of any slice of bacon
that we have ever seen and it has got
eyes and a mouth too but worst of all
when you hug it it says I'm bacon
maybe the makers of this toy didn't
actually want kids to eat meat in the
first place the Darr Bears did you have
a teddy bear when you were a child we
certainly did and we think that you and
a lot of the people you know did too
however we hope that your teddy bear was
nothing like this next collection of
bears here they are pretty scary right
we aren't entirely sure what it is about
them that wreaks us out so much perhaps
it's the oddness of their fur or maybe
it's the way their faces look less like
bears and more like people either way we
think that they are just way too creepy
we definitely wouldn't want to get a toy
like that as a present Teddy Ruxpin back
in the 1980s Teddy Ruxpin was a very
popular toy it wasn't that big for that
long but there was a period of time when
almost every kid had him or wanted to
have him he was a bear who read stories
you put a cassette in his back press
play and he'd read them to you however
looking back on it it was pretty creepy
it was a combination of things really
firstly there was the way that he stared
out at you that was worrying if you
added that to the way that he would read
out to you then it was the sort of thing
that could easily give a child
nightmares Furby some toys become
genuine pop culture phenomenon one great
example of this was the Furby if you
were a kid back in the 1990's we think
that you would have had one of these
they were like an animatronic pet you
had to look after it and it would talk
to you looking back on it it was a
pretty big surprise that we weren't more
creeped out by our fur bees think about
it they looked a bit odd and they talked
a lot there were even reports that they
used to turn themselves back on even
after they were sweet
stuff like we said spooky struts we
think that it's fair to say that my
little pony was and is a genuine
pop-culture phenomenon the toys have
inspired several generations of games TV
shows and even movies but when something
becomes popular it's not uncommon that
things inspired by it follow the lead
that's what happened with struts which
were like My Little Pony except a bit
more creepy they aren't as cartoony so
they have the unintentional result of
looking a bit like the sort of big horse
that would pick on the Little Ponies at
school we can't quite put our fingers on
it but they definitely creep us out
Cyclops brain baby stroller when a baby
gets a little bit older it will often
end up being taken out in a baby
stroller
they are usually fairly nice and
everyday things that is why we felt a
little bit icky by this thing that's
supposed to be a device for babies it's
a baby stroller but it doesn't look like
what what it looks like is a brain but
not just any sort of brain if you look
around the front it's a head but the
head only has one eye so it's a cyclops
brain baby stroller we don't know if
it's completely horrible or secretly
pretty cool Mexican jumping beans kids
quite often like toys that are a bit
unusual and a bit active something that
fits the bill was a toy that was a
pretty big hit back in the 1980s and the
1990s called
the Mexican jumping bean they were like
little beans that somehow mysteriously
jumped they were really using magnetic
forces however real jumping beans do
exist but they are a bit different they
are beans which have had moths lay eggs
into them and when the eggs hatch the
movement of their larvae makes it look
like they are jumping we think that is
pretty gross Mickey Mouse perhaps the
most iconic and recognizable cartoon
character in history is Disney's Mickey
Mouse he's been entertaining children
since 1928 and we hope he continues to
do so he's inspired a lot of merchandise
which is usually pretty cool however
there's one time when we pretty much
wish that he hadn't and that's for this
toy it was made by a company called
Dean's rag but he doesn't quite look
like the Mickey that we all know in love
he seems a bit too thin
his eyes and teeth make us feel very
weird and very uncomfortable vending
machine toy miniature toys or the sort
of thing that's a cross between a
keyring and a toy are pretty cool and it
can be fun to try your luck and get
something fun from a toys vending
machine however this toy isn't that sort
of thing we want to see when we open a
capsule it comes from Japan and we think
it's appeal must be lost in translation
we think it's probably an alien of some
kind but what makes it creepy is its
color pattern it looks like it's got the
same sort of colour as human flesh
creepy robot there's a word for things
that give an impression of what people
from the past thought the future was
going to look like the word is retro
futuristic normally things that our
retro futuristic are pretty cool like an
old episode of the Jetsons
this toy is retro futuristic but not in
a good way
take a look at this robot and we think
that you'll agree that it looks pretty
scary it has bright red staring eyes
that's bad enough but take a look at its
mouth and in particular its teeth we
can't think of any scenario when we
would feel happy playing with it
Breaking Bad dolls Breaking Bad was a
genuine TV phenomenon and it generated
its own line of merchandise these
included action figures based on the
show's two main protagonists Walter
White and Jesse Pinkman they were
actually pulled from Toys R Us shelves
in Florida after a petition accused them
of promoting illegal activity we know
that they weren't intended for kids but
we think that dolls are usually kids
toys when you think about these dolls
you'll hopefully agree why we are
putting them in here we don't think that
children need to be subjected to the
sort of things that happened in Breaking
Bad pregnant doll it's fair to say that
no one here would have been alive if
they had not been born however when one
toy manufacturer came up with this next
toy there was controversy
it's a pregnant doll and it comes with a
baby that you can remove from its
stomach nope we're not kidding
while childbirth is an incredibly
beautiful thing some people thought that
this doll was just a little bit too much
for young children but we really want to
know what weird toys did you play with
when you were a child don't be shy let
us know and tell us in the comments and
that's it for 20 creepiest toys no kid
would want as a present thanks for
watching end
forget to subscribe
[Music]